.
AND FORMER PRESIDENTS ARE NO
DIFFERENT.
>> NOW, TRUMP'S ATTORNEY ACCUSED
NEW YORK'S ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
PUSHING HER OWN POLITICAL
AGENDA.
JAMES GAVE CREDIT TODAY TO
DONALD TRUMP'S FORMER ATTORNEY,
MICHAEL COHEN, FOR HELPING TO
LAUNCH THIS THREE-YEAR
INVESTIGATION.
>> I WILL REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THIS INVESTIGATION ONLY STARTED
AFTER MICHAEL COHEN, THE FORMER
LAWYER, HIS FORMER LAWYER
TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS AND
SHED LIGHT ON THIS MISCONDUCT.
AND THE REMEDIES ARE CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE HAVE SOUGHT FOR
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT COMMITTED
THE SAME MISCONDUCT.
>> JOINING US IS THE FORMER
PERSONAL ATTORNEY OF DONALD
TRUMP, MICHAEL COHEN.
MICHAEL, GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
>> SHE GAVE YOU CREDIT THAT YOU
LAUNCHED THIS INVESTIGATION.
I REMEMBER, WE ALL DO, WHEN YOU
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
AND SAID THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF
FUDGING OF THE NUMBERS GOING ON.
DID YOU KNOW THE SCOPE OF IT?
DID YOU KNOW THAT THERE WERE 200
FALSE OR MISLEADING STATEMENTS
ABOUT HIS ASSETS OVER THE YEARS?
>> THERE MAY HAVE BEEN TWO OR
THREE THAT I WASN'T AWARE OF,
BUT THE REST I WAS.
AND THESE WERE PART OF THE
TOPICS THAT I SPOKE WITH NOT
ONLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, NOT
ONLY THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, BUT
SEVEN DIFFERENT CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES.
I'VE JUST GOT TO SAY, THANK GOT
FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL JAMES.
SHE'S TENACIOUS AND FEROCIOUS,
SHE'S WHAT OVER ATTORNEY GENERAL
SHOULD BE LIKE AND I GIVE HER
THE ABSOLUTE GREATEST OF PROPS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AT THE CENTER
OF A WEB OF INVESTIGATIONS.
WE CAN PUT IT UP ON THE SCREEN
JUST TO SHOW HOW MANY.
BUT THIS INVESTIGATION, WHAT WAS
ANNOUNCED TODAY, THE VALUATIONS,
WHAT IT GOES ON, THE SPECIFIC
IMAGE OF DONALD TRUMP, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THIS MEANS TO HIM?
>> TO HIS IMAGE IT'S A COMPLETE
DESTRUCTION.
IT'S LIKE A NUCLEAR BOMB
EXPLODED.
THE MAN HAS A FRAGILE EGO, WHICH
WE ALL KNOW.
HIS ENTIRE LIFE IS PREDICATED ON
HIS NET WORTH AND HIM PORTRAYING
HIMSELF AS THIS WONDERFUL
BUSINESSMAN, THIS MASSIVE
SUCCESS, THIS INCREDIBLY WEALTHY
GUY.
AND WHAT DO WE KNOW?
WE KNOW THAT IT'S NOT TRUE.
WE KNOW THAT -- AND I'VE BEEN
SAYING THIS NOW FOR YEARS, THAT
THIS IS AN INFLATION OF HIS
ASSETS AND DEFLATING THEM FOR
TAX PURPOSES.
I DO JUST WANT TO SAY IN YOUR
OPENING SHE'S SUING FOR $250
MILLION.
THAT'S THE BASELINE SHE'S GOING
AFTER.
I SUSPECT IT WILL BE SOMEWHERE
THREE TO FOUR TIMES THAT AMOUNT
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
>> MICHAEL, CAN YOU JUST TAKE US
IN THE ROOM WITH DONALD TRUMP.
WHEN HE IS CLAIMING THAT HIS
APARTMENT IS 30,000 SQUARE FEET
BUT IT IS CLEARLY 10,000 SQUARE
FEET, BUT HE IS FILLING OUT THE
PAPERWORK AND CLAIMING THAT IT'S
THREE TIMES THE SIZE, DO YOU OR
DOES ANYONE IN THAT ROOM TELL
THE EMPEROR HE HAS NO CLOTHES?
HOW DOES HE DO THAT?
WHAT'S THAT CONVERSATION?
>> YOU DON'T TELL THE EMPEROR
THAT HE'S NAKED, OTHERWISE YOU
LOSE YOUR JOB ON THE SPOT.
IT WASN'T SPECIFIC TO, HEY,
LET'S JUST LOOK AT THIS, IT'S
33,000 SQUARE FEET WHEN IT'S
ACTUALLY 11,000 OR 10,000.
WHAT HE WOULD DO IS HE WOULD
SAY, MY APARTMENT IS WORTH $375
MILLION, SO ALLEN WEISSELBERG
AND I WOULD WRITE THAT NUMBER
DOWN IN RED AND USE IT IN ORDER
TO BACK INTO THE NUMBER HE
WANTED, WHICH WAS A NUMBER TO
INCREASE HIS NET WORTH FROM,
LITERALLY, AND THIS IS TRUE -- I
SAT IN THE OFFICE ONCE.
HE WENT FROM RAISING IT TO $6
BILLION, NO, I'M ACTUALLY RICHER
THAN THAT, BROUGHT IT TO
$7.5 BILLION, TO $9 BILLION, TO
$10 BILLION, IN A PERIOD OF 60
SECONDS.
HE'S MADE MORE MONEY THAN ANYONE
IN THAT SHORT SPAN OF TIME EVER.
>> WHILE THAT'S HAPPENING,
YOU'RE JUST WATCHING HIM GOING,
OKAY, SURE?
>> I WAS TASKED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BACK THE NUMBERS USING
HIS ASSETS INTO WHAT HE WANTED.
THERE WAS NO AND THERE IS NO
TELLING HIM NO.
THAT'S ALSO A PROBLEM WE SAW
DURING HIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE ARE FAMILIAR, OBVIOUSLY,
WITH THE TRUMPS HERE, WITH THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
ALLEN WEISSELBERG OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
>> JEFF McCONY IS AN ASSISTANT
CONTROLLER.
IF WE WERE GOING TO PUT THIS
INTO PERSPECTIVE, DONALD TRUMP
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE BANK.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE BRANCH
MANAGER, ALLEN WEISSELBERG, JEFF
McCONNEY WOULD BE THE TELLER.
WHATEVER YOU HAD FIRST WENT TO
ALLEN, BUT IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
SIGNED OFF BY DONALD IN ORDER
FOR THIS THING TO BECOME
EFFECTIVE.
SO THAT'S WHY WHEN I ALWAYS SAY
THAT DONALD KNEW EVERYTHING
ABOUT EVERYTHING GOING ON AT THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
>> HOW ABOUT HIS KIDS?
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAID WAS THAT THEY WERE
BASICALLY INVOLVED.
LET ME READ IT TO YOU.
AS EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENTS OF
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION, DONALD
TRUMP JR., IVANKA TRUMP AND ERIC
TRUMP KNEW AND PARTICIPATED IN
THE SCHEME.
THE THREE CHILDREN WERE
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
OPERATION OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION'S BUSINESS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
THAT THEY KNOWINGLY
PARTICIPATED?
>> SO, AGAIN, IT'S A SMALL
FAMILY COMPANY.
THIS IS NOT, YOU KNOW, IBM OR
GOOGLE OR META.
THIS IS THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
IT'S A SMALL, VERY CLOSE-KNIT,
AND THERE WERE OTHER THAN THEM,
EIGHT ADDITIONAL, NINE
ADDITIONAL EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENTS, MYSELF INCLUDED.
SO, YES, THEY WERE INTIMATELY
AWARE OF EVERYTHING.
AND IF THEY WEREN'T INTIMATELY
AWARE, THEY BECAME INTIMATELY
AWARE WHEN IT WAS THEIR NEED TO
USE THE PERSONAL FINANCIAL
STATEMENT FOR EITHER A PROJECT,
TO GET A LOAN, FOR INSURANCE, ET
CETERA.
>> THEY WOULD DO THE SAME THING,
THEY WOULD INFLATE THINGS?
>> WELL, NO.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE TRUMP --
DONALD'S PERSONAL FINANCIAL
STATEMENT.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THEIR PERSONAL
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS.
IT WASN'T RELATIVE TO MY JOB.
>> ACCORDING TO THIS FILING,
THERE WAS OBVIOUSLY AN EFFORT TO
COVER ALL OF THIS UP.
ACCORDING TO THE WRITINGS, TO
COVER UP THE SCHEME, TRUMP WOULD
TELL HIS AGENTS TO NOT PUT
ANYTHING IN WRITING.
IN FACT, HIS TAX ATTORNEY PUT IN
WRITING, DON'T PUT THIS IN
WRITING, SAYING PLEASE USE FRESH
EMAIL WHEN COMMUNICATING WITH
APPRAISERS SO THEY AVOID THE
EXTENT OF POSSIBLE EMAIL CHAINS.
WAS IT JUST WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE WAS WRONG?
>> RIGHT.
SO, AGAIN, THIS IS TYPICAL
DONALD TRUMP MOB-LIKE TACTIC.
HE LEARNED ALL OF THIS EARLY,
EARLY ON, AND HE REFUSED, ALWAYS
REFUSED TO HAVE A COMPUTER, AND
ESPECIALLY AN EMAIL ADDRESS.
SO THESE TYPE OF COMMUNICATIONS
ARE ALWAYS BETWEEN OTHER PEOPLE
AND THE PERSON THAT HE'S
INTENDING THE RESULT.
WHEN IT CAME TO THE, AGAIN,
APPRAISALS, THIS WAS ALL SET UP,
AGAIN, BETWEEN ALLEN WEISSELBERG
AND KUSHNER OR ANYBODY ELSE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS ALLEN
WEISSELBERG WAS BROUGHT INTO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
>> IF THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE
TRUE, HOW DID HE GET AWAY WITH
IT FOR SO LONG?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THE SYSTEM PROTECTS THE RICH.
DONALD TRUMP HAS ALWAYS SET
HIMSELF OUT AS SOMEONE WHO IS
WILLING TO FIGHT, TO FIGHT TO
THE DEATH, ESPECIALLY IF IT HAS
TO DO WITH A LEGAL ISSUE.
AND YOU SAW HE DID THE SAME WITH
SCHNEIDERMAN, WITH TRUMP
UNIVERSITY AND SO ON.
HE WILL FIGHT YOU TO THE DEATH.
AND A LOT OF THE PROSECUTORS,
YOU KNOW, SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK, WHEN THEY DROPPED THE
12 SEALED INDICTMENTS, BRAGG, BY
NOT GOING FORWARD EARLY ON,
THAT'S WHY I SAY TISH JAMES IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF PROSECUTOR,
THE TYPE OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT NEW YORK, AND ACTUALLY ALL
STATES, NEED DESPERATELY.
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN THREE AND A
HALF Y